hi everyone and thank you for joining us
today I'm Kristen Pascal I'm a
connectivity manager at Wolfram research
based in one of our office is located in
Lima Peru it's a nice view of the
Pacific Ocean from here
my group worlds aren't connecting the
world from language to external services
through functions like servers connect
we could be the data with image search
and so on and now we are introducing new
experimental functions with our new 11.3
version to interact with different blog
chains from the world from language so
let's start with a general overview what
we can know so we have first awesome
read all the functions that will allow
you to connect and extract information
from different blog chains and some
functions to write to in this case our
own world from blockchain so we have
this set of five basic functions that
are fully documented and with this you
will able to interact with some blog
chains to specify a blockchain you can
use the dollar blockchain base variable
or the blockchain base option for now
the wall from blockchain supports the
Bitcoin blockchain theory blockchain and
the world from blockchain so let's start
with some cool stuff we can deal with
these functions let's just increase the
size a little bit here okay all right so
let's start with the blockchain data
function the blockchain data function
allows you to get basically information
about specific blockchain so let's start
with the Bitcoin blockchain
okay so with this I said by default
blockchain is a beacon one it will tell
the world from language to use the
beacon blockchain with all these
functions so let's try something first
so I'll see a blockchain data are the
Bitcoin blockchain that you see I get
some basic information about the beacon
blockchain blockchain native function as
well as the other functions support
different properties that again they are
fully documented and they are labeled so
in this case I can ask let's see let's
ask for the latest hash and the blocks
which is the height the current height
of the Bitcoin blockchain I can do the
same with an era blockchain let's say
this here in blockchain I'm currently
using the Bitcoin one but as I mentioned
before even if I have said the dollar a
blockchain based variable to Bitcoin or
an era blockchain I can change this
locally using the blockchain base option
so let's just hit theorem watching here
and see what we get okay so again I get
different information from the current
blockchain as you see it's different
information because there are different
block chains they deal with different
cryptocurrencies and different
properties so let's try doing
let's get the longest price the medium
and the highest price cycle do something
like for example this okay
so we have seen some general information
about the blood chains now let's go a
little bit deeper and explore the blocks
themselves so remember I'm working with
a Bitcoin as my default blockchain so
let's just get some and any random block
here and I get more information about
the block so what is something more
interesting maybe let's say we can get
the latest block by doing logic block
data minus 1 this will get the latest
mind block of the Bitcoin watching as
you can see here the transaction list is
longer than the one we'd get here if
this one is a very old block this one is
the most recent one let me hide this so
let's do something less get the
transaction list of the last
okay and let's say let's get a a Brandon
sample office list okay this is just one
random transaction of the last current
block so we can use these to explore our
third function here is the blockchain
transaction data with this function we
go even deeper into the blockchain and
Explorer transaction itself so remember
we have this transaction and let's try
doing blockchain transaction data of
this transaction okay so once again I
have a a set of properties related to
this transaction in this case of a
Bitcoin transaction so let's do some
cool stuff with a Wolfram language so
remember I save these as a variable
sighting have to call the blockchain
again in this case for example let's get
total beacons that's the total amount of
bitcoins transfer in these specific
transaction so as you see here we really
return the data as bitcoins so we can do
something like this since since then
well from knowledge base also supports
and knows about different
cryptocurrencies we can do a currency
convert of all these bitcoins to let's
u.s. dollars so we should get the
current price of this amount of bitcoins
but in u.s. dollars let's say we want to
explore the fees awarded in this
transaction once again we return the
fees not in bitcoins but as Satoshi's
which is a basic unit of bitcoins it is
also supported by the Wolfram language
so let's say let's convert these to US
Dollars and we could do the same with
any other supported currency all right
so we had this mythical transaction so
what happens if I try to look for this
transaction but in the fearing
blockchain well this is not going to
work because this transaction doesn't
exist in the field blocking there are
different block chains and this one
doesn't even have the same structure as
an if your transaction ID but let's keep
exploring the blockchain
the theorem blockchain so let's get the
last block from the theorem blockchain
all right we have a transaction list
here and let's just pick any random
transaction so we can do let's say the
transaction data base transaction ID you
seem a theorem blockchain base so the
transaction existed in the it's your
block changing so let's see what we get
here so again we have different
properties different from the Bitcoin
blockchain and once again we can play
with these properties using the world
from language let's say we want to see
the total way it's the ways in its a the
basic amount of either in the if you're
blogging so we can do currency convert
of this amount to let's say eaters and
we get the current price and what's to
this once again and now let's convert
these ethers to US dollars okay so this
is all handled by the Wolfram language
but return to our Bitcoin transaction
now let's explore the inputs of this
transaction so let's say I won
and when the inputs and from here I want
to extract the input script
so let's creep byte array okay I have a
script now so we're still working on
having a better representation of these
scripts and that will be supported in
future versions but let's see what we
can do with what we have here so let's
try to decode this byte array talking we
just get some random data but maybe
let's try another transaction from the
door block let's say this one here let's
drag the transaction lease and they want
the first transaction this is a very old
block and from here we can do blockchain
transaction data to explore different
section and I want the inputs alright
and from here let's tract scrape my
dream okay so let's try these
one more time to see what we get
unless in this case we got some metadata
from the miner
so with these three functions I'll show
you you can connect to these three block
chains the Bitcoin did here in the water
from blockchain and extract information
that can be used to explore all this
data so let's now move to the read and
write functions so for now the Wolfram
language supports writing only to the
Wolfram language to the world from block
chaining me so let's change our
blockchain base to old friend our
approach is to use a Wolfram blockchain
as a public ledger to store any kind of
data just arbitrary data so let's say
for example we'll do a web image search
our rival rival move it buster
yeah let's just get its time middle so
we don't want big images here because we
have block size limit of eight megabytes
so let's just try with one of these let
me get a random sample this first all
and then just one one here let me try
again
okay I'm sorry I just like the UFO
alright so we have a image here and to
save data into our blockchain we just
have to use a block input function so
let's say we just want to store this
image here so this year
turn transaction ID this one let's say
the easy to know variable and of course
we can explore the details of the
transaction using the blockchain
transaction dated function so let's try
is here and as I showed you before
you'll get a set of properties then we
can explore again but let's see a nerd
thing so one cool thing about this
function and another blockchain is that
anyone using a Wolfram language that has
this transaction ID can get the
information I save to our blog chain
just by using the blockchain gate
function so remember we have this unless
you see you're blocking it of this
transaction ID all right so I got my UFO
but actually if you see this I'm not the
only guy that UFO I get a complete
structure of a list of one element which
is a UFO it's here this is the actual
thing I save so if I do this here half a
UFO so that is I can save any kind of
water language expression to our blog
gene let's say let's try mmm a random
graph all right
so let's do a blog chin put up this
graph
I know anyone with this transaction ID
can do watching it and you get the graph
here so I mentioned that we have a block
size limit of 8 megabytes so if we try
to save something that is too big let's
try from simple this I shall get an
error saying that this is too big so
actually even even if the block has a
max size of 8 megabytes the information
here has to be a little bit smaller than
that because he had to consider the
block headers and polar data so these
are the functions that will allow you to
interact with our world from blockchain
and more block chains in future releases